all right and we are live the last word
with law kognito and Ibanez returns hot
by the campfire and actually hot is
actually really accurate for what we're
about to talk about later
yeah well it's that's fitting as the
fires will be burning mm-hmm very very
hot very solarii hot but a man what's
been going on with you have you been sir
and i'm world st and otherwise otherwise
probably more destiny a little less
which we'll talk about for me I saw the
the new activity come and launch and we
will definitely talk about that this
final assault is worth deep discussion
on many fronts but then mostly from but
last week when we got done playing and
then now I've been playing most every
waking moment with Star Wars Jedi fall
in order so we will save that discussion
to the end but as we both been playing
it and enjoying it and definitely want
to talk about that one with you guys so
that one will be tucked at the end I'll
try and even throw timestamp in there
for you guys so if you want to jump into
that discussion you can't but yeah just
a little bit of Destiny where needed but
mostly Star Wars just has my attention
and now it's a blast what about you
pretty much we in the same boat not as
much destin this week but um Star Wars
fallen order of course but know a touch
a little bit dere's been a lot of
project x cloud touching for me I've
been in the beta so now I've been doing
both console streaming as well as what
you call the X cloud itself and I'm
having a blast with that but uh yeah man
I mean I did touch the effects offensive
final sort which we will get to have a
lot to say about that as we fix our
faces this man I'm not gonna like
revitalise me I was gonna come in with a
different approach today but then I saw
the swab and then my approach cut it
change a little bit so yeah I don't
think people would have been ready for
my approach free if this [ __ ] didn't
happen well see that's the joys of the
balancing act that tightrope that Bungie
walks very well but I want to thank all
of you guys for tuning in live on
twitch.tv slash
Pontus think you guys for catching the
show in live and chatting with us so
thank you guys for that one you guys are
listening on audio you can catch us on
video or live on Twitch but if you catch
us on video it's either on the iron
Lords podcast YouTube channel check it
out there or on my channel we put the
video up on both so you guys got places
to watch us but before we get going we
get to do our audio podcast through
anchor so I want to give them a little
shout out in a spot so we'll take a mini
break here for the little sponsor spot
and we will be right back alright guys
so yeah anchor honestly has been great
for the podcast thank you guys all last
few ones we're getting over 300 listens
which is in the grand scheme may not
sound like a lot but I was like thank
you guys because trust me as that number
keeps growing we just no more you guys
get to hear and listen to us fill your
ears on the roads or while you're
walking around cleaning something
working on your house wherever it's that
podcasts are nice on the go I know when
I found podcasts like it's been a game
changer for me so if you guys enjoy us
talking for two hours believe me it's
appreciated so yes sir
well yeah we had a couple things
happened with destiny this week we are
gonna start with the big elephant in the
room the vex offensive final assault so
we know going into last week we have the
table we had nothing we had the weekend
still nothing we knew there was the
construction the tower for my Korra is
just just you know house I think there's
a dude still working apparently he
doesn't scaffold and still going he's
gonna make sure it's secure he's the
maintenance crew he's got to be out
there working but then Tuesday we know
is coming it's the last bit on the
calendar and the calendar this season
has been not also I mean all that's been
mostly pretty solid me the rage
challenge is a way to market but it's
both overall been like really good like
we've had the you know dungeon and we've
had the exotics come through and the
different difficulties and they've had
like Italy stuff that's been worthwhile
putting on there and then then we come
to the end the final three weeks of the
season we have the director's cut from
Luke Smith talking about like
eret of momentum and moving forward and
you want to be there for the moments and
then we log in on Tuesday whoa what do
we get sir kognito what do we get we get
that hot fire of nothing it wasn't
totally nothing we get that smooth
boring transition of no cinema and speak
to I could actually have some focal
right she had some vocal she had some
some things she had to say when you talk
to her and then um yes some exposition
and it was like hey go to the map like I
saw your video shout out the bonds
here's a great video right now
discussing what I'm about to discuss and
um yeah we just went over to regular old
vex offensive with no pinnacle we have a
reward and chess you know just get out
there and it's the same activity vex
offensive and you get to the end and
boom no actually I will say this there
was some ghost dialogue about the
undying mind during the vex offensive
and no yes shout - sinister no imago
loop so that day goes that little theory
and rumor and we get there and it's the
undying mind with the same mechanics
cranium shield and alright felt a little
easier actually then the other boss I
would say and you can it depends on when
you played and depending on us I think
some people went in being like hey I'm
stocked you ready to lock like knock it
down and then I went on Thursday and I
think everybody's just farming undying
cuz they're just using like pew pew baby
weapons and it's just gonna taken longer
so you know I've seen people one phase
that though which was not happening on
the Minotaur yes you know you did it in
a little more exposition about hey we
got to keep doing this a thousand more
times and will eventually stop this
thing and yeah so that was that and um
you know the tower pretty much looks the
same um it actually was kind of very
disappointing is it still looks like it
was in construction and it's not
finished
you know I'm saying so that's another
thing and really nothing after so I'm
gonna talk back to
you yeah a lot to say about this um you
know how long how long you got oh we got
time we can we can I got I got nothing
but time baby okay so um yeah I'm gonna
give you the last word on this one oh
dear in the sense of your doodles
obviously there's been some controversy
on prostate controversy but there's been
some dialog on Twitter and it shot the
Lord addict meaning we're talking about
this as well you know what are your
thoughts about the undermine conclusion
quote-unquote conclusion yeah so there's
a giant asterisks in that's at the end
of everything that I say because we are
three days into the final salt curtain
we don't know in two-and-a-half weeks
when the season transition comes if in
the next week something will happen and
then the final week something will
happen and then when it comes to the
final season when we go into the season
of dawn which seems to be about fire
which we'll get to later all of that
stuff technibond is killing me over
there what they want to have happen we
haven't seen yet mm-hmm so the big the
transition the moment that you want to
be there for whatever's gonna be like
the kick you into the next season with a
whole bunch of leg energy and everything
and everybody ready to go mm-hmm we
don't have that yet is basically the
nicest way this isn't you should have
been near win moment not yet now yet is
the big key word because as they've said
like the transition the transition
that's in two and a half weeks we don't
know anything about that we don't know
anything about next season and it's in
two and a half weeks which is also will
say no calendar no no a whole lot of
nothing so the big question there is
right now we get this new calendar
activity but as you said we go in and we
get literally nothing different except
the boss you you have a brand that goes
the NGO said coupler laugh okay core has
a few lines the ghost has a couple of
lines and then when they ask and then we
have to transmat in the portal which I
will give them at least a small shred of
decency because they're not actually
turning the thing on in the tower and
being like oh we blow up the second
tower crap so we don't have to cross
that bridge which would have probably
been more interesting sadly but we don't
have that one
you transmat in the undying mind and as
you said the mechanics are exactly the
same you have the shield up you kill the
Minotaur so you break his shield he's
just got the rotating shields kill him
done mm-hmm there are no new weapons
there is no new armor there is no
special legendary weapon it's not a
random quest
there's not even there's not a pinnacle
drop which will cover that in a second
but there's not even a powerful drop on
it anymore which I don't even know why
that went away
yo forgot right it was just out of it
use the blades there they used to be a
tier 2 and then I Cora was a tier 3 I
remember because that was like dozen
weird number choice but mm-hmm
it's plate that's not even there so some
people I mean there been a whole lot of
speculation undying mind okay
undying mind was the destiny one strike
boss hmm it was farmed quite a bit
because people wanted the imago loop as
you said yes mago loop was potentially
for those of you guys who don't know a
near copy to fate bringer which a gun
everybody loved which is one that you
won't shut up about in vault of glass ha
ha ha that's right baby
beautiful new pool but it was a really
good weapon and it was like later on in
this the history of destiny 1 when they
brought this weapon back and people like
hey this thing actually can't get damn
good rolls on it well its grind for it
has some really good potential they
didn't bring that back that could have
been even just that alone just adding
that in somebody sees it drop you're
like I got new Mago Lupin dude the world
would go nuts that is like something one
weapon could have done a lot for this
thing you don't have to do an entire
full quest lion go over here talk to 20
people one weapon drop could have done
just enough to be like hey it's a new
boss we get a new weapon nope not from
what we've seen at least again we're
recording this thing on November
20 seconds so if you guys are listening
to this like two weeks from now and we
sound strange because we're real wrong
hey that happens but as of now we're
talking with the facts that we know mhm
my hope as I think I probably said it
even last week like there was that
portal sitting in the back a unused
portal so you'd get up to the like first
floor clear out the crystals second
floor clear out the crystals top floor
there was the portal in the back and my
hope was that we could actually like get
up there we'd do something and then we'd
go through the portal to fight the
undying mind in its realm or something
and even if they just took the strike
room of the boss fight because it's got
a shield wall in it as soon as you go in
there anyway literally just put that
room on the other side of the portal and
let me fight him in there late that
would have been cool that room but
actually with six people would have been
absolute chaos if you have a bunch of
atoms ads in there but also a lot of fun
I think that would have kind of given it
a little bit of life and stuff like that
but nope nope that so I in for me it
sounds broken yeah you're so broken I've
never seen like you saw worse to me like
usually without disappointed like I go
off but you sound like a broken man like
this really hurt your soul like it did
mine I'll just it's just what I think
they had a lot of potential in many
different ways now this also is not a
pinnacle drop yes and I think it's ten I
I read through like I posted the video
of yesterday because I wanted to see
some comments and there were quite a few
good ones on my video because you guys
were bringing up ideas even festival the
lost had a pinnacle drop and this
doesn't like this is your season it's
gonna be here for a whopping three weeks
why not give it a pinnacle to a slap on
the hand mm-hmm but why not even have
this thing be a pinnacle drop because
it's three weeks into the season we
still don't know what's gonna happen
with levels if low knows gonna be right
and we're all going back down and we're
just working on that artifact again or
if we're jumping up to it nobody knows
that but either way there's literally no
drops from this that can help anybody
even
level mm-hmm somebody jumps in late in
the season well their incentive to play
this thing is very minimal if they're
gonna waste their time instead of
leveling up like there's no very minimal
benefit and if you have your excuse me
mmm if you have your rolls on your
weapons already that's it you're done
the only con this the only incentive in
there is for you is undying and that is
probably what half the people are gonna
be in there doing like shooting
everything with bows and fusion rifles
and just interrogatories but other than
that title that's I mm-hmm I don't see
much going on right now it's it's not
gonna get a lot of love so yeah but you
know I mean you'd literally transition
him in what I want to talk about because
initially before I read the 12 this was
gonna be my tone and um you know with
broken Guardian discussion right now cuz
that's where I was I'll be honest II you
know I love this game and this is not a
bad shadow keep it's not a bad dlc let's
just put that out there
right now however we said last last word
we said you know it's very good it's
gonna be very interesting how they end
this dlc and we all agree to start it
off extremely strong you know I think we
had it right now behind you know
battling for third place with rise of
iron behind forsaken and um taking kick
and to me ending with a you know a boom
a nice surprise and again we're saying
this right now November 22nd right in
two weeks something could happen and we
can have those moments maybe we have you
know like an older in kind of moment
like forsaken hat or we have some type
of thing that's the real transition but
as of now we got to rate it where it's
at and right now it's disappointing the
way it's ending right it just doesn't
feel good and then for me I'm gonna be
brutally honest like you said I've
gotten everything I need to get I've
gotten the interface I've gotten most of
my Pentacles I really don't have here's
my main issue with the play the pinnacle
structure is set up it's just the raid
master Nightmare hunts nightfall and my
main issue
is the pinnacle activities the majority
let's iron banner comes around right the
majority of them are non match made
activities yep that is annoying and I
become someone becoming a solo player
like you lately right
so it's like vampire anyway so yeah I'm
a vampire so my schedule is different
and it's just frustrating that I you
know I can't get a pinnacle without
that's why I lived in there I am Batman
someone that's why because I'm at least
I can play that solo and get a chance
for pinnacles and the other thing that
really is frustrating is that your
sinister get a timeline get came back
you're hilarious
uh-huh but you know that the thing
that's frustrating is that you know when
you look out to ask across you have some
good video some good Ram videos but on
when you look at crucible you know and
you just look at other activities just
there's nothing I can really do as a
solo player to get the pinnacles besides
this other way of just leveling up the
artifact and just playing redundant
stuff over and over and over again I
really want you know that direct path so
that's what's frustrating that if I can
rank up you know if I was to prestige in
predator and you know you're not getting
any prisms you're not getting any
pinnacles there's really no incentive to
play crucible hardcore I'm the crucible
guy I love being in there except when I
am Banner comes around so now all these
activities are shrunk down into
uselessness for me which then makes my
incentive to play less so which brings
me to this week this week's comes along
I'm like alright story beat right now
we're gonna see what's going on
undying mind is here you and I'm saying
and I shot the vagabonds I think I've
fallen order K my word we're gonna talk
about that thank God I did come on girls
playing that well you know I'm gonna be
I'm gonna be really once
I saw your video and I saw a lot of the
destined community say what this is no
and there was no drop there was no
nothing and it was just like yeah you
beat it and have a nice night I was like
I'm not doing this for like two day I'll
wait there was no rush for me I said I'm
gonna continue playing fall in order I'm
gonna continue doing these other things
until we actually get something that I
have
to do and that's when I felt I'm like oh
they're not ending this good you know
I'm saying so we shall see history
better yeah again this is November 22nd
right I do
I had this are a big argument where I
was no I shouldn't say but a big
discussion with my boy Lord addict and
he's like oh no man it's spooky this is
terrible
and he you know he's right I can't knock
that all I'm gonna say is this according
to Luke right and according to the
director's cut each season is going to
transition into another season with you
should have been there moment with a
story be with something I am hopeful
that this is not it that we are going to
get something that's gonna show us why
season of dawn is here so I'm gonna give
them that leeway because there are two
weeks you know I'm saying and hopefully
we get that moment I doubt it's a zero
hour you know I'm saying I doubt there's
anything like that let's say that at all
right but if we get something narrative
ly to the effect of remember how cool it
was when you went to Morris drone and
you saw that that hourglass yeah and we
all saw it we went crazy you know I mean
so hopefully oh that's all I can say but
if they don't have a lot to say boy cuz
it's spooky right now yeah I mean I'm
with you on that hopefully there's
something for transition something
towards the end of the season something
to give it you know the final send-off
of the VEX like the other thing to
remember is the VEX offensive going away
in three weeks that activity is straight
up god I mean for some it's actually
been like it's been nicely like
rewarding you get a lot of drops in
there you do actually like see a fair
amount for not overly long about
activity we're also when we stop that
we're also gonna stop the VEX invasions
on the moon which is gonna take the moon
to be a little more tame i like seeing
those giant circle
and I yeah those look really cool so
both of those are going away now that
doesn't mean nothing has happened to
anything else in the game hopefully it
does and again the seasons gonna explain
that but for now we're losing stuff from
what we've been doing the moon is going
to feel a little more on the tame side
which is kind of sad which we assume
yeah we knew that was coming but it's
also like mmm but also it's the it's the
other things of like not one other gun
not any other room not one other
mechanic not a pinnacle drop none of
those things helped at all like none of
those changes that could have been put
put in maybe in two and half weeks they
are going to absolutely blow up the
universe who knows like that maybe then
it's gonna go crazy but right now at
least for the activity that you did give
us to play there is no nothing to give
it distinction from the past 7 weeks
that we've been at this there's no way
to say hey should I really log in and
like play this thing and I was like I
didn't play it until yesterday I'm gonna
be honest I literally I was sitting at
work I was I was not gonna be home for a
reset I was at work a little longer than
normal I pulled him twitch just to see
who's plan I pulled up like bro man and
one or two others and I was like hey
there and there let's see what's going
on
mm-hm and then I was like okay it looks
the same looks the same he come and then
this was like alright so I basically
shut down that went did work came home
but then I'm sitting there touring I'm
like do I want to work on destiny or
don't wanna play Star Wars fall in order
a new game of the weekend like freshener
and I was just like I don't I mean I
have the undying title I need to work on
some stuff in there but it's like is the
undying mind section of final assault
anything but like it was really gonna
pull me in right now no and it wasn't so
if something happens in the next couple
weeks this is where I'll leave it it's
like you guys know I'm disappointed
because there is a laundry list of
things they could have done mmm some
more major like adding another room to
fight the undying mind that's not small
or adding a loop drop we're making it
pinnacle or any of those other things
could have been something so
for me if they do something else and it
gives a little bit but right now my
grade on its pretty low whoa whoa just
as like if you're gonna and this is the
what they really gonna learn their
calendar matters to the community those
of us that follow the Bungie like actual
blog and go see hey there's this
calendar this thing has a spot on that
and if they didn't learn that with arc
week that was a moment that was like
okay this should not be a calendar thing
but that's exactly how this feels is
like this is a non-event even lo no I
heard him talk about it too after I did
my I was like I want to record mine
before I listen to anybody else heard
his and he was just like even you could
have had altar of sorrow be one week the
dungeon be the next there's a lead-in to
that and then that would have filled up
your little you know perfectly
symmetrical calendar that you guys are
going for if that's what you wanted to
fill yeah yeah man I mean it again I
think it even starts from the very
beginning with vex offensive you have a
new activity that you want people to
play but you're not making it a pinnacle
reward like yeah why why this is what
you want us to be doing like again I
always felt that was a misstep again I
get the whole thing of making other
things powerful where not everything is
gonna be a pinnacle job I actually like
the levels and the the separation on the
map telling you what is gonna be what
but when you limit everything to
non-match main activities it really is a
problem especially with your new
activity you want incentive to that new
activity so I think that was a huge
missed opportunity you've already we've
already said it at nauseam how some type
of reward drop tomorrow
but whatever would also grant granted a
lot of incentive so yeah like I was
coming into this as I yo he not gonna
like me this last word you know I didn't
know how you feel I know I felt you were
kind of this until I put my video until
I saw the video on my okay cuz I don't
feel bad now cuz I'm like I'm gonna be a
grouch I'm gonna be mrs. negative they
not gonna like me at the campfire today
then I saw your video I was like yes
[Laughter]
you're in the middle of like some pop
and games coming out right now login
there was the bro I'm playing out of
worlds I'm playing um what's your cross
still finishing up gears fire okay I'm
playing three Game of the Year
candidates and Jedi falling over here so
it's not a game your candidate hey don't
they ain't gonna do that I play through
we ain't gonna say this would turn into
the last gift fob we don't want to do
that but we we just go disrespectfully
disagree but it's a good game that I
mean already got one on my back over
here thank you
listen bro you playing solos really muta
solo guys do you play and consistently
with three people and someone with Jack
it is a blast
it is I've have it did you play hard we
will leave this alone
this is this is this so sidetracked the
campfire and we don't want to do that
what we want to do is talk about been
there guess I was great tell him exactly
exactly I'll tell the cheetah was going
on here but you gotta let I like to
channel but all jokes aside now we're
getting the last word final assault
right now you know what I'm trying to
keep because this will be a three hour
show I really want to respect the time
of the listener yeah but y'all know how
I get I don't want to do that today we
got other things to another fish to fry
but anyway like I was saying the arm I
was becoming extremely negative me and
it's not until from me we'll get into it
when I saw the table that I felt even
though I'm not talking about the end of
this season but what's coming from us
from a subclass from a sandbox
standpoint really excites
so I don't know if much an addition now
but that's was a bit of a sideways you
can go for if you're gonna grumble all
the way through it but we are really
excited about this one yeah yeah but
yeah so the twelve did give us some news
still nothing about our activity this is
all we get is in the top I'm gonna read
this and this is why we're like maybe
we're not done bake giant question mark
stuck at the end of this one we wrapped
up festival loss this week but cleaning
up the decorations wasn't the only thing
that changed in the tower at core
finished her construction project closed
out all the permits and Guardians
launched an attack on the undying mind
the attack is ongoing and all season
pass holders can join in the vex
offensive and transmat the finished
portal doesn't look finished by the way
from the tower to some of the undying
mind to defeat the undying Minds from
different timelines
the impact of your victory has not been
made clear just yet but in time you will
learn more about how this will further
evolve the world as we transition into
next season so there do there is more to
come but definitely whether there is
still more to come the activity itself
had some missteps and I think we can
agree on that one yes yes solar winds
are afoot sir
the Sun has had a big solar flare and
the solar winds are going out into the
solar systems swear nice Olli shirt
today for this occasion got my solstice
I had to bring that soul out whoa there
we go there we go okay basically they
say in the combat system they said like
during each during some of these seasons
they want to look back at subclasses up
next the combat system is going to
tackle these solar subclasses big ones
they said they want to revisit some
older subclasses to freshen them up this
means older subclass perks has will feel
viable they're not gonna basically
reinvent the subclass it's still gonna
be like the burning Maul it's still
gonna be the Golden Gun you're not gonna
have like the flame ninja or something
like they're not gonna completely
rebuild them but they do want to tweak
these subclasses as we go through so
we've got three
we've got gun-sling or way of the
Sharpshooter bottom path you've got
sunbreaker and co2 the Devastator middle
path and then Don blade Skye a tune of
sky top bat path which one would you
like to start with sir kognito in order
start with the you know a lot going on
there get that crack in it
so they said traditionally the way the
sharp shoot has been mostly used in
specific PvE activities and almost
exclusively paired with celestial
Nighthawk helm it's the one that gives
you guys the precision damage bonus and
things like that you have the three shot
gets more damage as you shoot so for the
three shot we increase the auto aim
distance and reliability when aiming
down sights as it fulfills the role for
a longer range shot as opposed to for
the six shot we shorten the damage
fall-off range to emphasize the short
range gunfighter with the role of
killing a lot of people and that makes
sense I'm not gonna go shoot a boss
halfway across the room or the map with
the four with the six shot typically the
six shot is like clear clear clear clear
clear and as you can continually get
bullets back in that gun over time clear
a lot of ads so they're giving those two
a bit more of a distinction then we also
get down to we've made other changes to
the way of the outlaw to help keep its
potency like adding a new explosive
proximity knife that can stick to the
surface and detonate when enemies pass
nearby so I'm wondering cuz right now
the trip basically have two tripmines
yes I still wish you could unicorn
somebody with a trip mind
hey I would be okay with it and I would
I would hate my head be in unicorn but
it's still hilarious and it's worth it
if you can land it
but yes Filosa proximity knife sounds
kind of like a trip mind if you get in
proximity it explodes question is how
big is the explosion does it kill you
and or is it just like like I'm gonna
like bruise my shoulder with well I
would scratch
is it worth it right it's correct but
they wanted way the Sharpshooter would
feel more active rewarding for players
who can feel fulfil the role of the
Sharpshooter by taking down enemies with
accuracy
and precision so one of those out there
we actually talked about this before we
always talk about shoulder charge and
hand held supernova and it sounds like
you're getting another one of those by
the way but we'll get to that
hey go Cho star slandering don't you
start you know sounds just like all Jews
don't you even start all right you you
you this is about the hunted don't you
throw the Warlocks land in it's trying
to slip it in during the hunt to Sigma I
see what you do I see what you do
continue but we did actually say the
hunters and fairness do not have a
1-shot Hayley mmm that's not gonna be
that that's not gonna be the way anymore
the new weighted knife high damage when
I throw with a long wind-up travels at
high speeds bounces once and does extra
damage to the head precision shot final
blows recharge the melee completely mmm
one-hit precision final blows in PvP
hunters shut up I don't want to hear
nothing no more I got in a row I don't
want to hear anything from hunters
anymore
this right here well-deserved fire
you guys need it a one hit because we
got these Titans running around Titans
running around that are doing this show
the foolishness with no skill involved
Alicia
you know what I like about these hunters
at least your one hit melee requires
skill you have to get a precision you're
just gotta run mindlessly across the map
and just throw your knee out and get
instant one hit your you in an zone of
me you're also gonna die
that's not precision you my friends are
sub the subclass of skill and bungees
rewarding that skill we're not gonna do
mindless titan smashing and stuff like
that this is what you guys need I'm
happy I'm very happy my hunter brothers
he's out he's out he's I deal with it
this is the warlocks and the hunters we
got to come together against the evil
Titans man this is what we took
this is what we're talking about right
the one hit melee potential this is
beautiful I am very happy I'm very proud
this is this is important man shout out
to the gunslingers out here shout to
sinister this is great man I love you
this is a good day
they gonna have to work now they gonna
have to work that's what I like they got
less excuses so that's but no honestly
it's like in fairness like I always
thought the throwing knife if you get
hit him in the head it ought to be if I
take a note on the head I'm done yes
makes perfect sense to me so I honestly
totally approve it it is slower it's
gonna travel fast the montage of the
bounce kills are going to probably ruin
it when somebody does that finally but I
cannot wait to see that one overall
there's enough things that kill me add
one more to the list just makes it a
little more fun for everybody and this
is a highly skilled thing but if you
land it and that is gonna be feeling
good and you get to throw it again
you're like food get some in the head
yeah all right hold on
got it back boom it's like it's not
gonna be like throwing darts not let me
get quick like it's gonna be like
getting ready to throw like a small
hatchet or a tomahawk like it's gonna
have it's gonna have a weight to that
throw so you're gonna have to get ready
and time it but I'm I'm you would think
somebody who does just this mindless
shoulder charging would be it would be
upset about this but honestly I'm
totally fine absolutely none at all zero
skill no planning at none absolutely
just completely mindless easy kills all
the time totally and yours is not some
class specific I mean you know I want to
yeah you don't I don't even I don't even
need ability energy I can do it at will
just at my beck and call it is a rate so
awesome oh that easy button that's right
yeah staples there right in my back
pocket man practice makes perfect
this is quality of life lasts longer but
gives you a bit less energy per second
precision hits grant two stacks this is
the point of me not playing a hunter in
a whiles like what does quality of life
mm yeah practice makes for inter in
trance with each precision [ __ ]
precision shot hold on I got a timestamp
that one minutes remember that guys
think about the children at the campus
scuse me guys had to bleep one a flub
two were lovely anyways first ever
practice makes perfect
yeah enter a trance with each precision
hit reducing the cooldown of your super
knife juggler kills grant super energy
so a little less but overall still a
good thing sir just can't get over that
there's gonna be a beep in there be like
I thought this was a family-friendly
episode I'm gonna complain I'm sorry
I will actually won't even beep it I'll
just mute myself honestly do better
where's Captain America language
language did he just say language yes he
knew knock him down precision final
blows increase weapons stability and abs
speed timer starts at 10 seconds but any
additional final blow slash assists can
increase at up to 25 seconds casting
your super with this buff above 20
seconds consumes the buff in grants
extra damage does not stack alas alas
steel Nighthawk mm there's gonna be some
science done with that one yeah
precision final blows really an 80s
bebraud neutral game and they're saying
that's a new perk so actually changing a
bird that's new game bro starts at 10
seconds for any additional can increase
so you can start they think about the
synergy with that right mm-hmm
if you start getting into a flow so the
previous perk was line him up precision
hits with Golden Gun increase its damage
and extend its duration right you still
only get three shots you don't really
need a longer duration the damage isn't
a bad thing but this is I guess your way
to make precision shots matter and then
crowd-pleaser but still there enables
with golden gun precision heads generate
orbs of light so wait a minute no knock
him down is gonna take the place of the
one I just said
line them up is still there old perks
from crowd-pleaser and are now part of
this perfect golden can cause precision
damage and precision shots generate orbs
of light okay okay okay they move that
over there and then knock him down is in
the bottom one so they move some stuff
around but honestly it's just it's
they're rewarding the precision gunplay
so if you're gonna be running Scouts or
pulses or giving a lot of headshots from
range you're gonna get rewarded for it I
guess this is one of those points where
it's like when you get rewarded for your
scout rifle shots yeah there's a point
you can kind of make a build for this
but I still always feel most of these
skill trees do not really steer anybody
they're not powerful enough they they
typically steer people completely away
from the meta at least in PVE pvp maybe
somewhat but in PvE I never feel like
the skill trees like really push me to
play a specific way most of the time but
that's just me well so I don't keep
talking you can talk about the warlock
because I know that's your name yeah we
get about that oh yeah you know
definitely get actually I want to do it
the opposite way a faction let me talk
about the Titan and then ask your
opinion now you talk about the Warlock
and eyes might be okay a little back and
forth it's like we have a dialogue going
on the weirdest thing yes Sun break if
you're ready code of the Devastator
middle path Titans adhere to the code of
the Devastator so let's get what they're
talking about so right now they said you
know what if you guys want to crush with
your smoldering hammers want to live
your dream but their data indicate that
the subclass was underperforming in PvP
and that is the truth we've decided to
make a few changes that should enable it
to be more competitive the roaring flame
perk has received a significant bump to
its bonus damage and the buff Nayla last
25% longer making it easier to build to
retain stacks between encounters the
base damage of throwing hammer melee
ability has increased it's now very
lethal in PvP when you have roaring
flames active in addition once you throw
the
hammer and it's lying on the ground you
don't have to get quite as close to pick
it up
finally we tune the super in a number of
ways for starters burning mole now lasts
longer giving you more time to use it
strategically instead of simply spamming
and slam button Titans like when it is
smash all we want to do mindlessly smash
Bally smash we also increase the height
of the heavy slam explosion so the super
should feel much more potent against
airborne enemies that's nice that's good
you guys first up they're gonna get you
out of the air yeah and the hunters that
was jumping over you guys that's that's
a big one so throwing hammer increased
impact damage from 100 to 120 and
increased hammer pickup radius from 2
meters to 3.5 meters adjusted hammer
throw animations to fit a more damaging
attack and then roaring flames increased
damage bonus from 10% per stack to 25%
per stack in PvP and increased duration
from 15 seconds to 20 seconds and
burning mall that's the actual supercell
increased duration from 21 point two
sections to twenty-eight point five
numbers that is crazy how long is that
how long is that super last like 20
seconds no how long is that super last
twenty one point two seven three nine
and two seconds like oh my god like I
was wondering how they set along these
No yeah yeah it is interesting why he
said I would love it you know why it's
twenty one point two and then now and
twenty-eight point five why is it not
twenty eight point six why is it not
twenty eight point four
like that is so specific blows my mind
anyway I'm sorry yeah yeah no this is
this is interesting me a twenty second
light attack reduce light attack energy
cost from 5 percent to 3 percent
adjusted the animation so that it flows
seamlessly into chained like attacked
Wow without stopping heavy attack ground
slam attack now detonates when it
detects enemies above it
detonation radius was increased to make
landing attacks more consistent
increased energy costs from 6 percent
8% whoa
birdie ball e how are you feeling I
haven't used this that much because it's
never been like I still love the range
of throwing the hammers having them
explode and also you've got the usually
melting point to weaken bosses and then
in PvP unless you just have like a nice
path for this thing to travel down it's
really hard to catch people with the
slam and then like I'm like I have a big
slits like trying to go run after
somebody with a sledgehammer it's big
it's awkward it's slower it's not really
it's kind of gangly it's not it's not my
little like Oh gotcha
like it's not the same so all these
changes sound positive I don't know if
they're gonna be enough to pull people
away like me from my throwing hammers
that I can Chum halfway across the map
and nail somebody on point B that's fun
but if you know if I can get on level
ground and actually go have that path go
up there and it's gonna get everybody in
the realm mm-hmm maybe I mean it's
definitely gonna be one to try the
throwing hammer could be fun
roaring flames damage bonus seems
actually pretty nice as well so there's
definitely some potential here what
about PvE
it's not a kind of PvE think about the
like vagabond Oh said like the the mob
clearing like oh ya know that crazy
yeah the mob clear and throwing the
hammer picking it up quicker getting it
back out there faster having roaring
flames go like I know people have some
fun builds with the throwing camera
alone just like tink okay tink and now
start when hitting people as they keep
getting it going which is kind of cool
in a super the last 30 seconds as you
use it obviously if you sat there it
would take 30 seconds to go away but I
mean still just cheaper light attacks if
you're going for enemies and then smash
a couple times obviously it sounds like
it sounds like it's getting a little bit
of much-needed love in some places this
Forte would just show up today
gaming for TR boy yes right now
Forte with the sub said Fred by the way
23 minutes ago I think I missed that one
also for 12 months sir thank you for the
year welcome to the fam of course but
gaming Forte for the tier 1 sub for six
months sorry mom it's my bro that's
what's that binge salute the Forte
but yeah overall I mean I think I'll
just have to get him
Hansen tested it's still one of those
when it comes to risk versus reward and
that's usually the big thing for me as
throwing hammers not the melee one in
this class I'm talking about the other
ones is like if I do a melee that hits
hard enough like melting point that
shoulder charge melee in PvE is really
strong so then if I do that and weak in
them and then can turn around and maybe
pop my super and do that much more
that's still a powerful powerful
combination so I'm gonna have to see how
this pairs up and see how it goes the
range above is actually gonna be a nice
thing because if they're airborne or
floating enemies or something that's
like a little farther from the radius
then it doesn't catch it that it
actually potentially should give it a
little more a little more aim assist a
little more love and the freedom of
killing people with a big slam on the
ground so hopefully that slam hits even
harder now and we will see how it goes
but I mean I don't see anything wrong
with this I just don't know if it's
enough until I get my hands on it
okay so right now not not sexy enough to
pull you away just yet I was I just love
my throwing hammers I gotta try it but I
love my throwing hammers that's just
I've loved that since it they came and
taken kings so I've been kinda biased
would you stop Titans get the love of
senator this man is just listen I don't
like Titans like much either but Jesus
they needed this once that is like no
one's using burning more like burn Amal
was cute that first week forsaken
everybody was like yeah we going back to
throwing hammers and everything else
they they they needed that one bro come
on let's be nice you know but oh yeah
he's like everything listen to that gun
sling is fire right now like I really
would go do that but continue oh yeah so
give it back to you we've got the John
blade atonement of flu I mean sky you
are the Karate Kid ninja
so they said with a two-minute sky they
wanted to push air supplier superiority
gameplay further when we initially
released this path its movement
capabilities were toonder and the
original destiny 2 gameplay experience
which was much slower with more
deliberate positioning things have
changed obviously so basically what they
want to do is they've reduced this
which burst glide accelerates players in
daybreak so you can't literally skate
around the map thank God killing by
being killed by that it lasts a long
time and then if likes those wonderful
typically like skaters can go through
it's even faster so when they get to the
other side and they kill you again it's
just like yeah and I know Titans had the
same thing going on but yes that one I
know has been curtailed this one like
the flying dude when I watch a video I'm
like you're so fast like they can really
cover some ground it's impressive so a
little slower there which is probably
okay we know this is a controversial
change but we wanted to reserve the air
superiority gameplay with a two-minute
sky and burst glide speed was blurring
the lines between both daybreak paths
hmm Icarus dashes while in daybreak have
increased speed and thrust to recapture
the burst glide gameplay for those
running air superiority paths so
balancing it out we hope that this we
hope that while this change is different
you still feel as fast as before but
with maybe a bit more expression behind
that speed there are the changes are
below new celestial fire melee send a
spiral of three explosive solar
projectiles this is literally yeah can
somebody like frame cap that by the way
please
that is kind of terrifying this is solar
handheld supernova all over again
so what it sounds like stop we don't
know if I got a hold on I'm talking sir
I'm going through and I'll give it back
to you my opinions first you would got
to do with this cylinder continued heat
rises consumer grenade to extend glide
time and dramatically reduce in air
accuracy pinnacle penalties for weapons
well for the skilled players I could see
this being potential but you're also
giving up a grenade so I'll be curious
their opinions their wing its son rework
fire weapons use celestial fire
what's fire weapons oh you slide fire
and throw grenade while gliding oh you
can do everything while gliding now yes
airborne final blows grant melee energy
and extend of the duration of heat rises
you'll be floating four at four days sir
four days mm-hmm
Icarus - tap crouch twice - dodge in
mid-air oh that's my baby
dodging in daybreak and you just
basically took a Titan exotic why did we
get ripped off what that yeah we but we
had it already we've had this ability
already yeah but we had the enemy shoot
no no you guys got enough this is our
time to dodging in daybreak accelerates
players farther and cost less super
energy while under the effects of heat
rises No due to the nature of these very
work swing at Sun wings of sacred dawn
received a buff where it gains 15%
damage resistance wild tome of dawn is
all right mr. warlock man tell us what
you think
let's see yo boy lacks a floof gang
floof gagging yo let me tell you I sold
man this was the subclass that when I
first first played d2 the potential was
so amazing I remember throwing that
weight wings the second drum sounded
weak the second does such a beautiful
exactly and um I was like man it's so
cool but it was just so weak because you
were in the air you were a target and
now with all of these changes first of
all shout out to the melee first the
fact that they added a new melee
animation so this is pretty much the
essential of um what's the one from the
Warlock that shoots the Dragon Ball Z um
like a smoke tail straight right so yeah
so pretty much it's chaos reached it
that class is mainly when you throw
something at it right I doubt it's gonna
be a one-hit kill but it's just a long a
projectile melee which is cool because
he's gonna give you some sexy sexy to
use while in this class that's under use
this class had a lot of potential one
other thing that I like with the heat
rise they've already had it but what's
cool it encourage you to stay in the air
you'd shoot guns and then from there as
long as you got killed
it would help recharge your abilities so
now they're saying yo charge up this
grenade that's gonna initiate heat rises
you get in the heat rises they want you
to get in the air so this is encouraging
getting there and what's cool is they
reworked sit there on the exotic the
swings are sacred dawn with the damage
resistance cuz that was my main thing
there was no reason to be doing all this
aerial stuff cuz people get out the air
you're not saying that's number one and
then number two the main beef was when
you were in the air because of the way
d2 was structured you wouldn't get the
UM the the in air accuracy they had all
these nerves to in air accuracy when you
shooting weapons and all this stuff so
being that heat rises now reduces that
penalty we're gonna have an air game bro
and and that it covers that that's like
um what's that joint that that exotic
y'all used to have what was it called
Twilight exotic you don't tell about
what type check chat yeah I know what it
is faster than I am someone's gonna be
faster this we forget the name of time I
like Harrison try like garrison
something garrison yeah dad is so useful
you know I'm saying being an air moving
around having that ability so that you
know what was cool so even if you hover
if someone got to drop when you boom
Ikaros dash forward back all this is
cool then they giving you speed with it
this is going to change the game for
warlocks top tree is gonna be finally
something sexy daybreak bottom she was
just too dominant the fact that you had
the super you you made it last all that
long and let's be real I like the fact
that they actually nerfed the movement
going around with that class as well
ignore you can be mobile in the air but
you shouldn't be able to get across the
map in three seconds
that's it yeah seems reasonable
shout-out to wish with day he said
grounded will smoke right listen man we
got to see we got to see at the end of
the day I just love the thought process
of the class which is getting in the air
being airborne
using this grenade this is gonna just
gonna create a whole new place now I'm
actually curious
in PvE how effective it is but I can't
wait now dusting off my own wings are
sacred dawn I can't wait read this this
is this is really exciting we're gonna
be out there thick Oh bro like this is
one of my favorite subclasses but I knew
half potential just wasn't executed
thankfully so thankfully Bungie went
back to a so this is it's a good day man
I'm excited like Solar needed some love
so yeah I mean all in all hopefully
we've got a couple definitely feel I
mean you've got a single shot melee for
a hunter you've got burning Maul
dependence really has more potential
explosion range usability and you've got
a tune of Skye where you guys are gonna
be flying around and living up there
forever but as they didn't say if
grounded is in session you guys better
take that subclass right off grounded
well the modifier and PvP will just kill
you don't do it it's not a good idea
what if I got my 15% of a sacred dog
15% doesn't cancel out like 50 do the
master come on listen that bottle flying
on me they all the time no it's nothing
just think if that thing comes up just
put this away any other time you want
things on don't go flew from around and
dying every I look up in your like
[Laughter]
believe you get my goes the big gotta
get it yeah good good subclass I love
that they given all these old
underperforming subclasses some love
hunters one-hit melee sorely needed
burning Maul sorely needed a rework and
of course you already know that top a
two-minute ask I get my now all I would
says all this solar love all this you
know all this dawn talk all this feeling
very Osiris II what courser feeling very
Osiris II that's that's all I'm saying
what do you think mercury the planet
closest to the Sun is any relation to
these solar subclass abilities in your
guy Osiris what
hey it's a lot of dots just see when
they come together him I don't know
please just see and that's kind of the
big questions like now we definitely
have like we heard season of dawn orb is
like okay we didn't have solar in the
artifact at all at all and now we're
seeing the kind of confirmation solar is
gonna be a thing in this season it's
definitely gonna be a factor so we don't
know much else about next season besides
the fact that we now know Solar will be
involved and the dawn of a new era
hopefully a good one talked about if
let's say you already know that's a like
listen I would just say this just seems
like a perfect setup for a certain NPC a
certain game mode that revolves around
mercury and the Sun kid your toasters
ready that's that I'm on with you
vagabond oh the stars may be aligning
for something magical if you lose I'm
gonna toast your but that's just gonna
grow if they bring trousers little side
yo I'm gonna go crazy you know it I
don't know if enough people have been
playing elimination because there's not
really incentive to go do it so really
have given them like feedback maybe they
have you know really big PvP community
people out there at a summit or
something like that who knows but right
now it seems like trials as mm doesn't
feel like it's coming if it does it just
feels like it's gonna be a huge surprise
a little bit ways off but we shall see
yeah touch on the news we do have iron
banner next week so during your
Thanksgiving holidays over the weekend
traveling and stuff like that
get some PvP in if you can get some
pinnacle drops if you can but iron
banner will be next week the usual iron
banner control at some point do you want
something besides control for iron
banner I think no but I believe only
because I just think we've had a banner
too much this season well because it
feel like it didn't feel like we just
had iron banner that's where we're
getting it every three weeks like every
two almost but yeah what's a lot who
weeks
yeah so I think like this is the new
pinnacle source thing and I think that's
orders I think if we miss it and we had
a little activity between it I wouldn't
be as mad but I don't know I'll be when
we tried I abandon the other things then
people complain it's not control I don't
like it so I rather them just leave it
and then direct it yeah yeah just shut
up and do it and add other activities
and space it out
so we miss it a little bit that's just
me so honestly I didn't think you know
I'd be like a fire this just popped in
my head I was like instead of control
you can do like iron Bay or like you
could do solar clot solar clash and it's
like in old-school NBA Jam te and if you
get three kills and Earl he's heating up
easy belt he's on fire and then all of a
sudden you walk around and everything
you do is just like crazy solar damage I
don't know see the goofy stuff like that
I don't know if they'll ever go quite
that far but it would be really fun if
they did yo black wings in rift now
bungy for things there's no rift please
I would like to see a rift though I
haven't played whistling I forgot what
the mode was that's how long it's been
for me what was rift pick up the orb Roe
and dunk it on the other person's side
[Music]
it's been so long you forgot I forgot
how riff played forgot the rift well
Duncan's you know the turnover back slam
double twister 180 spin gotta have some
style on those dunks gotta get some
bonus points dad and some SRL damage
what's that what that I'm not hold my
breath on that one no no I had fun in
that and I was actually pretty good I
love this irrelevant I was about mmhmm
yeah
iron banner next week so enjoy get some
pinnacles if you can hopefully we know
what the hell our level grind is gonna
look like next season sometime soon but
we don't know yet I don't know if they
do we'll see shout us everybody out
there the iPads for Kids program the
Bungie foundation all of you guys
through at least even my link I know we
passed two thousand dollars everyone
combined nice there were forty plus
thousand donors fifty five hundred
streamers who supported the campaign and
1.6 million was gathered for that ones
that is amazing guys so the game to give
will be going 1.6 million into the
Children's Miracle Network Hospitals for
the iPads for kids which is just awesome
shout out to all you guys
small applause I don't wanna clap too
loud oh yeah you guys are totally
awesome do you want to cook sir do you
want to learn how to cook destiny style
we've got the new official destiny
cookbook in collaboration with insight
editors and author Victoria Rosenthal
Destiny's first official cook book is
filled with recipes inspired by the
characters and locations seen throughout
its expansive universe did you I have no
say in this sir
page 74 in the index now when she's cake
will the cheesecake recipe be in here
sir I wish I had any part in this trust
me part of me also wants to go through
that us new cookbook is on the exo truck
gnarly when she does the where's er her
and she was saying it's like I'm gonna
do a full full cook through of the whole
cookbook on stream mm-hm
nice cookbook cook through is your solo
nightfall guide in the next video is
your solo hush puppies Fried Chicken
guide like that yo would have we fire
you know if you did a video like that I
go for an odd watched show black wings I
can't wait for upon just doing a cooking
Destiny's dream and that there we go yes
crunchy vex cookie cake from the moon
yeah and then my son works like what Dex
milk yeah page 60 68 is gonna be and a
box of raisins for you I'm gonna have to
find a way to acquire some vex milk
though because that will probably be
used in some recipes and we also have
grim more anthology three the grimoire
books are awesome so they come with this
one it's really weird they announce some
of the stuff so far in advance it's
coming in late 2020 that is like a year
away yes that's so long I'm in no rush
to preorder that one because I feel like
if I do order these books I by the time
they actually come become available like
did I even you
I don't even know so mm-hmm those are
coming I wanted to take a little brief
moment break off of the standard
discussion we had this thing called
stadia lunch yes about that sir explore
let's talk about shout out to Paul
Tassie with his amazing stadia
experiences and a shout out to Destin
Lee Geary he also was doing some testing
and polarizing let's just say that a lot
of people were talking about um first of
all shiny digital founded we got the
technical specs of it it is running 60
frames um it's a 4k upscale so it's not
it's technically 1080p on our honor on
an upscale so it's not the true 4k that
was promised but um you know for the
most part you know people have been
having issues and um yes Paul taxi he's
been he is his experience I've been
charting he's been really rough now we
don't you know I think he's based in
either Ohio Chicago no cities Midwest
and um I don't know if it's a datacenter
issue but he's been working with support
with cuz I saw some video and the frame
drops and it was just awful awful like
yeah it was like not clay this consist
mortal kombat 11 cutscene it was like a
voice was that I think it was yeah
then what was scary was he was talking
about player population trying to do
strikes him the only person in it you
know that's again the disadvantage of
not being linked with the PC in the
steam community and then being in its
own ecosystem who how many people really
have you know destiny on Stadium
you know I mean so you got that aspect
then you got to collect it collecting a
ship's aspect which I don't mind I mean
they needed to have the whole thing
they're a new platform I didn't mind
that as something exclusive to them but
um oh there's no deal better said 13
players in game it Wow is that true wow
that's crazy literally so it's 13
players in gambit start and then even
crucible was where's that image hold on
you keep talking I'm gonna look good
it's real spooky man so well yeah it's
just like you know um
again optimal conditions you know this
is a shot the digital family they had
like 200 up 200 down you know and he was
he was rockin they were rocking to help
you know but at the end of the day you
know how many people have that kind of a
setup
and again that's ideal set up with
nothing else on your network and all
that other stuff you know it is again I
haven't played on stadia yet I've just
played X cloud and you know at the end
of the day I've played destiny on X
cloud and I've had a great experience
you know I'm saying now was there some
lag yes there was it was minimal on some
level I felt more with jumping but uh
stairs got his work cut out if they've
got a lot to do you know and um to
convince people to try to go to this
platform and I don't know man I don't
know you know but um definitely some
spooky issues and um just some really
bad hiccups and stuff that I saw so
working approximate what was your
thought process on all the the stadia
stuff to choose on your beauties sir
there was a point where I thought about
getting it just cuz I was like hey if I
travel might be cool just take the puck
in a controller so glad it didn't I mean
from what I found for you just from what
I'm seeing it's just not there mmm
whether it's population as you said cuz
it is on its own still having to buy the
games the prolly I mean I've listened to
enough Cod cast the pricing model is
that one of the big issues like to enjoy
high res you gotta pay the fee then you
got to buy the games now I know some of
them like the day of I think got
discounted because a lot of these were
older games that it launched with and
you're like they were originally priced
at like I don't know full price you're
talking 50 60 bucks for games and then
if you had the pro version then you
could get some like having 50% off
discounts and stuff but these are still
old games we're talking about like tomb
raiders I'm like I'll seem this thing's
like 20 bucks maybe like why am I gonna
pay and there are some games where maybe
it's not as bad mmm but there's plenty
of games like I could see an adventure
game probably not being too bad
anything where it's precise Mortal
Kombat Dark Souls mmm like those things
where you need the precision the frames
you do not want any like input lag you
have an issue so I think for me just a
piece of stadia is the fact that the
population is not there for destiny now
and that's the free game well it's not
even really free because you really
gotta pay that 130 you will you're
getting the chromecast ultra and the
controller and the three three months
and you're getting some stuff with it
but in half the games free anyway so you
could just honestly log in as it is you
know what they told when he was having
the issues oh they were like the furnace
is turned down your fidelity that you
paid for remember you paid 130 to have
4k 60 frames per second that's what the
premium tier is for them to tell you to
fix it to bring it down at 1080p this
way what am I even paying for this for
it's like it's just a it's a glorified
beta and then on top of the last thing I
know you're not the biggest Microsoft
God but Project X cloud literally took
their lunch that last week oh no it's
like not theirs they literally dropped
50 games in there their beta of Project
X cloud not only performs better not
only has more functionality but you've
got game pass games and not only do you
have what's in the x cloud which is
amazing you can remote into your console
and play destiny whatever game you owned
on your xbox so it's just like yeah you
know right now just to have those games
dumb old games they got at that price to
me it's a glorified beta and you got a
worry with a Google the problem with
Google is that if things don't go right
they have been known you know I'm saying
to leave the platform to to run away
you know hangouts on air I mean we can
look the list goes on with platforms
that if it doesn't start on fire out the
gate Google will abandon still so we got
to see it right now it's a glorified
beta as far as I'm concerned and you
know hopefully it improves but you know
hopefully blunt you got a next check
that's all I hopefully buns you got a
nice checker sample put it out there but
I'm saying
like there then being like the forefront
on this thing is I don't want to say
it's bad for them but it's not helping
it's just it's a weird platform overall
it's a weird platform this is what I
think is going on my get my guess is
they definitely threw them a bag it
definitely dropped it a little back to
money truck up for them but I think as
an independent studio bungees looking at
it like you do oh yeah it did the bridge
truck came you don't say it was Google
Google Drive some money off for that for
that level of all exclusivity but I get
I don't even know if it's exclusive we
got to see the key I think for bungie is
to say hey look you want us where
independent studio let's maximize and
get our souls oh yeah its visibility for
them let them fight it out cuz no one
knew who was gonna win the streaming
wars
you still got Amazon coming up you know
X cloud is is still in beta put it on
everything it's just caching baby
so I'm mad at that but they need to get
on X cloud in the X loud because I'm
tell you right now I'm playing gears 5
on X cloud on my on my phone on cellular
network 4G LTE bro no noticeable lag in
party check insane and I was playing my
boy skybox was on PC and my other boy
was on them i watch go at it was on xbox
it's crazy
well what a cloud is doing is that it's
performance wise game wise they're
smashing tombs I don't know what they
gonna do but that just be yeah so yeah
stadia launched questionably if your
population issues are out there they're
shipping issues people are wanting
refunds because they're not gonna give
him for like a month and then mm-hmm
game launch list changes like the day
before and then they add it was 12 games
the two days before 22 games one day
before just one of those things that's
like I know like I hope it doesn't do
anything bad to Bungie I mean the
visibility is never bad and it's and
this is honestly for bunchy it makes
sense because to a see had a great thing
it was just like but this news cross say
if I go log in play with my characters
even if it's not the best still my guys
I'm not trying to go buy Borderlands 3
again start over characters grind stuff
know like all those oae my progress on
Tomb Raider I made it halfway through
and maybe I want to play this thing on
the go if I got some time
train now huh good point no very few
games have cross save good point they
don't even have an achievement system up
right now all the features that they
promised with the YouTube integration
they're not even ready shout the black
ones he said Google new Amazon was doing
a streaming service one to get theirs
out first
and in doing so they release that
unfinished product so they were shuttin
tell bus look I don't know if they're
gonna shut down but I do
Big Bear is yeah it was on coming too
really yeah there is some truth because
it felt like they were in a rush to
launch and that could be it they could
be sensing himself we gotta get to
market and then we'll just improve it
but again if it's not quality you know
the question comes down to II who is
this for who is the market I still can't
figure it out who's gonna pay outside of
us crazy
destiny fans who have cross say you know
but now you there's no population
destiny is the ultimate friend game
right like there's no population it's
like we gotta say we gotta say man but
it's look a little spooky for them yeah
little weird so but yeah there's a
couple other random issues people have
been killing that dungeon boss in crazy
fashion they said next week is gonna be
a short week so I wouldn't expect too
much in the tuam I know I'll be working
some of those days I don't know if
you'll be busy and stuff but I would not
bet on the last word next week a
convention it's just gonna be ultra
light and then who want to talk about
anthem when you get oh no we're not done
I'm just gonna run out just a [ __ ] yeah
but I didn't want to shout out destiny
getting couple nominations in the game
Awards though oh the game Awards mm-hmm
let's get it trying to actually get to
the game Awards mm-hmm but we've got
destiny got nominated in two categories
so I wanted to shut him out they did get
nomination for Best ongoing game they're
going up against apex legends Final
Fantasy 14 fortnight Rainbow six siege
so you've got some some heavy hitters in
there too
for definitely people who I mean apex I
probably wouldn't put that I fortnight
with his black hole thing may win just
because of the publicity stunt Final
Fantasy 14 I've heard awesome things
about with Shadow reborn or something
like whatever the newest thing is when a
Fantasy has made an amazing comeback
people love that game and that's
something actually pay a subscription
for and then seed just continues to do
its thing so mmm and the best community
supports the other one is apex destiny
final fantasy for tonight same thing
same ones like ongoing community support
of the same categories so so yeah it
looks like they were to use our sound
categories one was audio design mm-hmm
didn't see destiny there and then one
was score in music and yeah didn't see
destiny there so once again once again
destiny is not recognized for any
musical achievements so you know I gotta
talk about oh yeah this is a disgrace
this is a disgrace I'm sorry y'all like
we got a hold a feet to the fire and I
think again I understand
dusty may have a negative connotation
with hardcore gamers you know they may
have issues with the game itself and not
liking the loop but this has nothing to
do it this is musical achievement when
you listen sorry about the tavern I met
when you listen to destiny just the
title screen just floating in space some
cool things like leave I don't even need
to get into the specifics you already
know what time it is with this and it's
not even about being biased because I'm
a destiny fan good music is good music
this game has had it for the longest I
mean let's be even get nominated think
about this any people get nominated when
Marty O'Donnell was here when we had the
lowest a drunk with the spheres what's
the joke bro that's some of the most
beautiful August street music you've
ever heard
not even a nomination that's my problem
forget about winning the games not even
getting nominated we got a hold into the
fire yard we got
I'm telling you man we got a band up we
got to keep calling them out cuz this is
a travesty man maybe we could all we got
to do I figured out the solution you got
to do the Deaf stranding y'all we got a
call D jump and make sure deeds get in
there get your Geoff Keighley and them
guys to make it appearance in the game
okay we gotta get them in then destiny
and make them an MPC in destiny and
that's how destiny is gonna get
nominated shout out that strengthen
shatter conceive that's the only way no
cuz if you put Jeff in the game you got
a shot no it's not too soon me I'm in my
feelings do meant to I mean my feelings
we got to we got to do we got the pace
of people if we gotta grease some palms
we gotta do something look at me [ __ ] we
got a deuce that's four times y'all we
got to do something man this is the only
way y'all know what to do destiny
community which I notice it's all jokes
aside yeah I notice a travesty man
there's a there's no reason for this man
well on a positive note which is what I
was trying to get to I did was because
they got nominated now they are in like
the ongoing community support sections
so they seem to be liking existing games
that have been out for a while so maybe
one comes to nominations they're going
more for new releases mm-hmm
just a guess because I mean that could
be part of it we're talking about all
new games and most of these categories
and then we've got the ongoing and
that's where destiny is that it's an
ongoing game best ongoing music game
like I mean you're gonna get a little
specific with some awards but I mean
shout out to the music and the sound
design team of course they always do an
amazing job and I just kind of wish they
could get a chance for the recognition
this is again where destiny 3 that is
where that benefit of destiny 3 they get
them back on those awards lists for
everything game of the year come out
crush it space Doritos coming in music
is why not hold or shout the
black-winged my guy I know what you
talking about he said it's a piece of
music when it plays when we obey and it
starts out a few simple notes on a piano
and it's so damn beautiful it almost
brings tears am i it's a shame hitting
it bro there's that joint from shadow
key never sitting of it and it's like
did it in a minute of it didn't it
does that little little bro that that
little beat right there is fire like
it's so many little moments like one of
these epic songs is like the the halo
menu screen ah and then like every menus
every year we get a new like
orchestrated menu screen and destiny and
they're awesome
so gaming Forte I'm not trying to give
them a pass I just don't have the
nominations to work as this is an
ongoing thing they're going like hey
what are the games of the year well just
these military right here and that's one
that's more what I'm saying like no I'm
not giving the pass because honestly
like you listen to like this is destiny
to shadow keep soundtrack put that
against another soundtrack it's right
there with everybody else and you know
what I think what's happening I think
you nailed it I think part of the reason
is that they're considering destiny
there's still the 2017 game right when
any wind it doesn't eat too much 2017
yep right so they're still acting like
it's a 2017 game that doesn't count on a
yearly award thing and they're
disrespecting the expansions they're not
acting like an expansion is the new game
so when we getting a shadow keep and
we're getting all these expanses each
separate year they're not counting that
that's like oh that's old destiny you
said I'm saying and I think that's will
show you the only shot we have is these
old you know but the only thing is bro
wait are multi-play okay maybe they
don't give us that but okay but at the
end of the day like the only shot we
have now is these ongoing game kind of
categories that kind of thing and the
only hope now is destiny 3 right
whatever a destiny 3 is announced at
that point it's considered a new game so
I really don't want to hear it anymore
but you know we shall cross our fingers
win and if destiny 3 does get a lunch
and better be on some of these lists
yeah back to say it that's that'll be
your test to see who's doing the voting
up there and how that's working just get
Jeff to talk to deej put them both in a
game guarantee game of the Year
nomination brothers
just reading it what else we got man oh
we got this anthem thing man yeah you
want to talk about that what's up let me
let's get to it bro you don't listen man
have anthem gang y'all know I've been
very hard on y'all I've been very hard
on y'all you know I love the premise I
always felt the idea was cool I was one
of the very early supporters of the game
Iron Man the game we affectionately
called it and it started off very strong
and then ends with a bad girl shot
before I think you're right Bobby look
it came off a because I know what you
talking about
but oh yeah back back to it he stole it
might listen we all know the story of
anthem very disappointing tragic and
Bioware the whole bit but there are some
news floating around and all apparently
it's gonna be an anthem 2.0 anthem next
is in development so there is a breath
of life they are not abandoning a shout
to my boy dizzy who's got a great
article on our Lord's game gotten it
putting it in there for y'all so you can
see hopefully the video ain't no but um
yeah man it's it's a great article and
um basically Jason Schreyer has reported
that they are in developed there was a
serious rework going on a serious revamp
and I believe the last person who left
Chad Robertson he actually said it was
in good ads I know it doesn't sound good
that he left but yeah they're not giving
up on it so I just want to bring that
out there get your thoughts you know
with the whole thing you know do they
have a shot and um you know what what
shut the process behind it I mean it's
tough that game burned everybody I mean
it's not like a well-known franchise
like Diablo that launched with Diablo 3
with some issues and then Diablo 3 2.0
people like hey I did buy the game so
many people did because it was I'm
coming back because it's Blizzard ok
cool they made it good
but no man's sky I don't know how big
the population is I know a lot of people
really enjoy next but I don't know how
many people that is I don't know the
size of the playerbase
and while there may be some people to be
like hey you know no man's sky next is
freakin awesome it's really cool but if
you have like 2,000 people playing a
game in the entire world that's not that
many that are left so then it's like
what are your development efforts worth
and again this is the point where anthem
had a cool foundation the suits felt
cool like the Lightning abilities from
the storm like things were cool and fun
for a little bit but like the
progression was not there the the world
was weird the loading there there were
so many issues in such a broken game it
was rough like they had they had woody
wood like they had a technical demo is
the best way I could describe him yeah
they had a technical demo they had a
weird arbitrary story they could have
done a lot more build up before build up
after but they had a cool technical demo
and I actually personally I really enjoy
the hell of the technical demo like the
Interceptor felt fun fluid fast jumpy
around awesome swipe here go go go like
he was cool sitting up in the air
floating storm' lightning' calling it
down like those bits were fun but like
after a while you're going why am I
still messing with these bits they're
cool to see but it's like a VR tech demo
it's like it's a technical demonstration
of what the what it can do and I think
with the crazy insane history that that
thing had that piece of it yeah what's
cool but there just was nothing they had
built a framework of functionality and
there's nothing else on that game so I
don't know what they do if they like
rebuild a story do a prequel send it
forward if they even connect it to the
old thing do a final fantasy 14 blow up
the world and send you off to a new
plane and start over I don't know
but however they do it I do think it's
I'd like to see something good happen to
it but I'm definitely not gonna hold my
breath I honestly thought it was fun
like to fly around and do the stuff but
yeah I just I think it's been burned too
bad and like every community for it to
ever have a chance this damage is done I
mean here's the thing this is what
they're debating right now
go over it real quickly the first thing
that debating is how they're gonna do it
is it gonna be more of a larger update
like a taking king or a series of
smaller updates then the other thing to
deciding which is gonna be very critical
for them is if it's gonna be if this
anthem 2.0 is gonna be like a DLC
because at this point do you have the
audacity to charge people even if it's
completely revamped cuz they're talking
about breaking up one of the things they
said they say we're looking at breaking
up the need to go to four tarses after
every mission and then they're breaking
down what mission structure is in the
gameplay loop and how that whole thing
is which is cool I like that idea in
that discussion of breaking away well
you don't have to keep going back to
four tarsus again yeah yeah that's cool
however what's critical to me is they
might have to eat any idea of trying to
bring out a DLC because I think that's
gonna rub people the wrong way that
means a glitch yeah charge me to fix
your game only that's [ __ ] go for them
they have to do a they cannot be small
it has to be one big update I think that
is the only way you get people to even
log back in is be like anthem like 1.5
or whatever you call it brand-new if you
got it it's still there whatever like
that is the only way you'll ever get me
back I can say that you got a login and
it's gonna be gotta be like a 30 gig
download or whatever it is we've amped
it's gotta be free and you got you got a
really you gotta answer all the
questions and and and the thing that
concerns people had you know a lot of
people had issues a lot of people you
know one it's the support and they felt
burned so so like I don't know I just
want to bring it up you know cuz it's
been a while I sorted news and listen at
the end of the day I do hope they
haven't taken Kate moment as much as I
clown I do it would be cool and and at
least for next gen hardware as well cuz
us on pc we'd know how glorious that
game could look no we're not gay or pc
that game is phenomenal and still to
this day it is one of the most beautiful
looking games sewing consoles were
flying
all Borough Council's know despite y'all
I'll be it's just it's not it it's the
CPUs get handler but with next-gen
hardware maybe they do it you know yeah
a year or so or whatever maybe you know
comes out and see you know and in return
it's a better fashion that's what yeah
well one more thing before we go cuz I
want to talk about it cuz why haven't we
been playing destiny that much this game
called Star Wars fall in order I know
this is simply destiny podcast but this
is too damn good we got to talk about it
yes sir how say what you want man I got
a whole whole roll of stuff going in my
head other than me and full disclosure I
am NOT a Star Wars guy I'll be honest I
don't hate Star Wars
I'm just not the Star Wars hardcore guy
that's gonna tell you all this stuff and
no so deep about the lore it's a cool
fun event for me and the games I'm like
me
it's a like I've never been like oh this
is so cool I mean maybe kotor back in
the day you're I'm saying but I was so I
mean obviously when it came out and then
I seen who were making it I was all it's
just respawn respawn goes my dukes next
to Bungie but we spawn CD Projekt RED
there's a hierarchy Namco that's kind of
where I would my favorite guys right
obsidians come up there too
but um you know at the end of the day
I'm like okay star was gonna but then
when I saw responding okay this could be
good
tin my opinion respawn has not made a
wack game that's how high I value
respawn so then I went to e3 but it
actually was did this year early this
year I have behind the scenes at the EA
play with this game didn't get a chance
to play it was a demo close behind scene
blown away I was like yo this game looks
cool I'm very excited now right now the
game releases I'm like okay cool let's
get it let's see what's going on this
game within the first 15 minutes like we
talked offline
the game felt like the game of the year
like within the first 15 minutes of me
playing this game not only graphically
it's amazing not only the story beats
the platforming of like an uncharted the
deep this game I'm not a Star Wars guy
like that this game makes you feel like
a Jedi like feel like you're in a Star
Wars movie bro the force powers in the
thing and then the same when you reflect
a bullet back at somebody and it this
thing is and then the thing that I
really like is one thing at akin art
we're big about boss battles this thing
gives you the epic feel of a clash with
the cinematic flavor and you like oh
like they really have knocked this thing
out of the park I'm only a couple of
hours in maybe four or five hours and
I'm gonna get back to it
but yeah shot the black-winged it's like
Star Wars Dark Souls you know to write
an uncharted had a baby and you just mix
it with this great Star Wars universe
and it's just it's it's cool man so I'm
gonna let you talk I know you've got way
more hours than me how's your experience
where yeah I mean Suze I would give it
like 9 out of 10 it's definitely up
there it's not running perfectly smooth
so I mean optimization isn't perfect
there are a couple things here and there
but over like still 9 out of 10 easy for
me on this one that's just like nitpicky
stuff combat is hella fun it's
challenging I'm playing on Jetta what
difficulty are you playing on there's a
question yeah I ain't doing that
see Kuro stuff you doing no what are you
more I'm on three oh that wouldn't I'm
not a normal is whatever normal is I
don't normal humans that's me normal
human mode whatever the before Jedi
Master which is like oh look at the bars
that no they're all in the middle and
then there's Grandmaster below that I'm
not on that okay no I'm not doing I'm
not doing like my nude frame perfect
precision blocks and everything I'm not
I did want to kind of enjoy the game
because I got other stuff I got to do it
can't beat myself against the boss
forever but
Jedi Masters like and I heard that's
what they designed the game around mmm
so it feels I think Paul Tassie had a
like headline of like Star Wars Jedi
fallen order is baby's first Dark Souls
and that's okay
that's why I like it cuz I ain't doing
that sucker old craziness now I want my
sanity in xiaojie I mean you can go
difficult if you want to so they give
you the option but overall I think it's
it feels because I was in the middle of
a boss battle literally last night
before I went to sleep I tripped into
another one and when I fit and I was
just going through it took me four or
five tries I think not like a Sakura
like 2530 Oh My gods it was four or five
not too bad I mean it's not Grand Master
but man when you go in there and then
I'm not gonna spoil anything because
when you see it it happens but when
you're going through your blocking you
get the perfect moment and you're like
you see them coming you got the
unblockable see you got a dodge you get
around you get to swipe behind but
they're back in it and like the bosses
are legit so they're quick to get back
in your block and working down their
stamina meter and like Dark Souls games
feel cool and this is almost why for me
like Sakura one of my friends really
didn't like it as much because it was
not uh you had to learn the parry you
had to learn the power hairy ninja
teaching dodge like you had to get your
shots in but you had to parry that was
crucial and I think that's what this is
it's not just dodge you can do the just
dodging like Dark Souls but the parry is
where you'll break their stamina quicker
do didn't it feels like I am a new time
at perfume it's like unlike staggers and
back and a cymatic flare when you do
yeah it's like there's a little slowing
yeah exactly it's really cool and I
think this like Sakura trained me to
better it be a better Jedi so yes Sakura
is Jedi trainer in advance and but yeah
I was like I mean so many people have
been like it's uncharted in Dark Souls
you've got climbing you've got vines
you've got mobility you've got a little
bit of platforming not too much but
there's always a Miss that destiny
servers are completely offline what just
yeah shot right now
yeah shot
but boy the logo with the photo in the
Vagabond oh yeah man he said yeah the
desti one end to the investigator so we
picked a good time to talk about about
deserve video Wow
I'll get dessert in a second before we
go but yeah that's kind of good it's
perfect said court yeah segue as soon as
we stop talking about destiny I guess we
got to talk about destiny but the
service to come back it's all us it's
all the Jedi Mind powers that we've got
we've controlled it it's crazy but just
like I was playing the boss battle and
even though I'd died four or five times
I was literally loving every minute of
it because I was like sweet I get to do
this battle again cuz when you go up
against stormtroopers I'm like oh you
shoot tang yeah I blocked it and send it
back to him like that's not that's not
the challenge part like I like the
harder enemies in this game yes a fights
feel good it feels yeah usually it's
like you got the purge troopers the
black ones with kind of like whatever's
going on I fed it found new one those
are awesome and shout out like flora and
fauna you got plants and you got animals
the fauna will kick your butt in this
game yes dude there's like all this like
Ram slug thing and I was like what are
you vomiting like acid breath and then
there's this big crazy giant butt bug
jumping on me I'm like what is happening
right now and I'm like running away from
Flyer fireflies and slugs and bugs and
I'm like I am terrified more of those
than I am the humans yo you know what I
got a shot about though
respawn knows one of my favorite games
that they made is titanfall
right one of the things titanfall did
that reinvent to me just reach change
change the game as far as a platforming
is that wall right hmm when I saw that
install I said yes that I love that that
mobility I mean again and I just love
how the different the skill tree we'd
even talk about the skillet you know it
is it's really cool baby they got when
it's a travesty
speaking of Game Awards I think it's
launched that's all but actually it did
beat the deadline
but what they made a consensus jury call
not to include it because I guess they
felt all we're not you know we don't
want to spend the time to review it we
may not have enough time to review it in
their defense but it's a trust because
now it can't be what I think they're
gonna make it except technically but due
to their rules it technically can't even
be included next year but I hear the
rumor is they're going to include it but
here's the problem we all know later
yeah last of us to is come in and
conquer those two so III it sucks
because to me again I've played the
majority of all these games that are
nominated the smash is that you know
controls the second or no disrespect but
when I play Jedi again two hours in this
feels like the game of the year to me
that's just my opinion I'm not
I haven't played Esther and I know it's
very polarizing you know I'm saying
shout out to the FedEx workers out there
but at the end of the day I'm just
telling you how I feel this game right
here is it that's just me
well I mean there's the skill tree in it
is similar to Sakura where you open up
different abilities in different like
slashes or dodges or things like that so
the skill tree is cool so for nitpicks
the mudslides are a bit excessive and
long they're in there elijah the
mudslides that is they are their mud or
ice I haven't seen water yet but at some
point I can I can ice skate on my boots
or muds gate down long hills still have
enough force to jump across crazy
crevices and mm-hm and still keep going
so the other piece is
the boxes all the boxes you open every
single one of them
mm-hmm they're kind of lackluster in the
cosmetic you have like pieces for your
lightsaber oh you have skins for beady
wondering of skins for your ship but it
was like I don't know what else I want
in those but I want something else in
those cuz there's like I see the box I'm
like yeah that's white I have to go get
the box cool but what's in it nothing
really late I don't care so you look one
little bit of cosmetics I was like a
little bit more of something I don't
know what that double lightsaber did you
get that spoiler so I didn't say
anything there's a double lightsaber
everybody sorry sorry guys
trust me I almost said it earlier but I
stopped myself because when when it
happened it was like always like I'm
gonna put this hilt on my on my
lightsaber I was like oh cool you're
gonna keep it as like a keepsake and
then it comes out the other side it was
like holy [ __ ] exactly that was sick so
yeah no I mean that one and okay fine
now that we know exists the boss fight I
just got done doing first phase single
oh halfway through mmm the boss goes
both so I'm like alright I'll match you
and then you on it dude it's fire
it's so cool fighting and a dad yeah Oh
atsc that's little one fighting a little
guy those are cool like forest powers
that you get oh and the outside the
other description it's also a
Metroidvania yes Chavo Cubano does it
mean I don't think it requires an
internet connection at all I don't think
you have to be the EA servers I'm pretty
sure you can play offline completely
pretty sure that's a full single-player
no microtransactions just straight-up
Star Wars game he just want to know if
there's any internet connection I know
some single players I've had their
foolishness but I don't think I don't
think I haven't seemed like connecting
to servers or anything I really there's
nothing that I'll see connecting to when
you played again it's very minimalistic
when you start at the title screen yeah
so yeah I didn't see that but um yeah
it's it's a pickup guys I'm telling you
right now yeah
recommended enough either it's yeah
shout out the respawn man again I'm
telling y'all I haven't made a whack
game these are the guys that made the
call of duty's that transitioned to
modern warfare when they first came out
60 frames per second when it was a thing
in the 360 generation I mean these guys
they had titanfall I think titanfall 2
has one of the best stories
oh and no no spoiler she has one boy
addict who finished fallin order from
I've heard this from three people now no
spoilers
I think it's better it is yo it is one
of less an addict is the most picky
reviewer I know it is one of the best
endings I am hearing people are people
are saying wait till you ending it is
mind-blowing that's what people are
telling me and for hear that from my boy
add addict don't he will nitpick
greatness for him I was all I gotta see
now I heard two other friends that I
trust they just said yeah oh yeah shot
alright see the only negative the way he
be running he did run an animation at my
stream last night I'm like running
around I'm like he looks like sometimes
a robotic and another yes a little
nitpicky I was like okay the skating is
a little like kind of goofy like boxes
the cosmetics are kind of lackluster if
you're gonna go hunt them all down it's
pretty collectible like minimal stuff
but I mean overall gameplay run around
the exploration like the place I just
got done fighting that boss the scale of
what I just got done doing just and I
don't want to spoil it for you but it's
just like there's a there's a very
specific movie at references when you
get there you'll know so and it feels
like this dope you know even though it's
self-contained like it's such a good
story right that it's like yo like you
you want this to be a serious it's so
good I don't want it to be a one-off you
don't say like I want this to stay a rap
that's how good this thing is yeah I
mean as a black wing said you've got
like mandalorian fallen order rise of
Skywalker knows like Star Wars fans are
loving life right now they're having a
great time
Disney Plus is out there you know watch
everything again
it's a good time so but man for me I
will be streaming the rest of that thing
it is so much fun and it's been art it's
like I had that and I was like do I care
about finishing festival lost I was like
yeah I let the two trap I literally let
him go and they probably weren't even
they were literally bounties and tears
and I was just like it's not a big leap
I was like not as a way I don't care I'm
good I'm good what I got I'm fine it's
like I need to farm my undying stuff I
got a spin I got a balance my time split
in those but it's hard man it's almost
what I need to burn through Star Wars
quicker just so I can get back and like
at least check that box and so good so
we had to talk about it we'll keep going
and if one of us finishes it then
whoever finishes it first just don't
spoil it for the next but when we do
finish it will have to probably bring it
bring it back just to kinda yeah holy
crap round table itself yes sir but I
think that's all we got for the week
guys we are coming up on two hours just
about perfectly thank you guys for
tuning in this morning it's been awesome
star wars fallen order can't recommend
it enough destiny to you guys got to see
what's next
yeah next week's gonna be light so lay
it the next starts on December 10th
so the tuam on December 5th is gonna be
a big I have a feeling that's gonna be
just hopefully the bomb drop mm-hmm so
I'll be huge that will be the key what
do you got going on for the weekend you
you're doing much with the the ILP
Brethren over there at the round table
yes sir I got a nice one man we got a
special guest man it's going to be
developer from two ton studios they're
gonna be show cable I say showcasing
they're gonna be discussing their new
upcoming game it's called unto the end
so if you basically if anyone that
doesn't know about it it's um it's
basically going to be if you like games
like inside like games like limbo
out-of-this-world
atmospheric the game doesn't tell you
difficult but also it's gonna it's
pretty much like is this is like the
character looks like torment from Game
of Thrones hmm and he's trying to get
his family back in this world and he's
got to figure it out so shout out
to to turn studios they will beat on the
iron law podcast Sunday 11 a.m. Eastern
it's a it's a dope studio it's a
actually small studio husband-and-wife
team Wow so it's like literally you and
summer made a game you know say like
literally like they've been working on
it for the last three years so it's
pretty awesome please check us out
support on the island podcast YouTube
Sunday 11 a.m. Eastern
check us out we'll have the rest of the
Lord's in there we're probably sneaking
maybe 1 or 2 topics and of course you
know please support Lords of gaming
dotnet some great articles you can find
that anthem article I just told you
about that it's if it's still dying it
has its last breath as well as the other
great writers there's a there's a Jedi
we got our Jedi fallen order review up
right now fantastic my boy Lord Hector
he's been killing it so please check
that out and of course king of statues
all that good stuff with it I really
appreciate the support lately it's been
really cool to see a little bit of
growth but um yeah man that's what I got
of course on Fridays the best day of
destiny podcast you gonna hear what is
the last word Cheeta and ninja style
doing it up provide entertainment salute
to the chat yeah I was giving us life
today very entertaining very funny is
always a pleasure to do this for you
guys always fun yeah I mean we kind of
covered a lot this week on ups and downs
and things of that nature but the big
thing is go out there have a little bit
of fun if you enjoy any of the type of
games that we described Metroid cross
with unchartered crossed with Dark Souls
and you enjoy Star Wars get your butt in
that game it's awesome so far pick your
difficulty you don't have to kill
yourself over it but go and have a blast
enjoy it and I think this is where we'll
wrap it up so this has been episode
number 82 it was November 22nd of our
joyous podcasts that I do with my ninja
co-hosts over here so this is the
cheetah and the ninja signing off for
episode 82 thank you sir for this one
it's been a blast thank you everybody in
chat if you enjoy it drop a like leave a
comment check the comments to check out
where to support us and it has been the
last word